news alert
and that breaking first at five a
shooting investigation at western high
school involving both ccsd police and
metro it is happening now near bonanza
and decatur a good evening to you on
this tuesday thank you for joining us at
five i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez let's get right out to madison
kimbra who's been following the story
and has an update madison
a lot of commotion out here this area of
bonanza has been blocked off for over an
hour as you can see behind me now with
metro police and crime tape up bonanza
is closed in both directions from
decatur through estrella avenue
currently awaiting confirmation from
police on what exactly happened we did
however talk to students and parents
that say this stemmed from a student
bringing a gun to school another student
also says she heard gunshots i asked a
parent if she got any calls or email
about what happened
no we don't have any information by
email the school
is
very
proud conservative they don't share
information with parents i sent a test
to my daughter
and she already responded she said
something happened but
i don't know what happened
we are expecting police to brief at any
moment on what happened meanwhile
victoria saha is at umc talking to
people who say they were involved in the
incident victoria what can you tell us
thanks madison the family here tells me
they were not students at western high
school they were meeting up with other
students at the school that's when a
fight was about to start with another
group of students from western high
school then this group drove off then
they tell me school police surrounded
their car as they were trying to leave
the area but while they were leaving
their car moves toward police and that's
what prompted school police to draw
their weapons and shoot at the car we do
know two people were shot inside this
car a teen boy had a bullet graze his
shoulder the family tells me he is
expected to be ok there was another teen
girl shot inside this car but no word on
her condition the students drove off in
shock on what happened and then they
called a family member they then went to
umc again all this information is coming
from the family a group of teens who say
they were involved we are still waiting
from school police to confirm these
details reporting from umc victoria zaha
live local now